se niegan a olvidar la muerte del
general iraní kazem suleimán y miles de
partidarios del grupo paramilitar chiíta
hasan shavit se reunieron en bagdad para
conmemorar el asesinato de su alemán y
el líder iraquí a wood maría luján dis
quienes perdieron la vida en el ataque
aéreo no tripulado de las fuerzas
armadas estadounidenses el 3 de enero de
2020 justicia por la sangre de los
mártires y la completa salida de las
fuerzas extranjeras en irak no aceptamos
nada menos no dejaremos de perseguir ese
objetivo y no dudamos las fuerzas
extranjeras deben salir completamente
del territorio iraquí debemos lograr la
completa soberanía nacional de irak
desde la invasión liderada por estados
unidos en 2003 que derrocó al dictador
suní saddam hussein el pueblo iraquí ha
pedido insistentemente que la presencia
extranjera en cualquiera de sus formas
se retire de su territorio este sábado
varias organizaciones de irak
respaldadas por teherán reunieron a sus
líderes chiíes en distintas ciudades
para enviar un mensaje claro a eeuu
y le decimos a los estadounidenses que
sólo unos ilusos si piensan que matando
a abu macd y al mojan dis ya qasem
soleimani le quitan la soberanía de irak
queremos decirles que eso es
completamente falso teherán por su parte
busca conservar su profunda influencia
en irak mientras mantiene tensas
negociaciones con las principales
potencias mundiales que buscan revivir
el acuerdo nuclear de irán de 2015